nadège abderrazak qui suit avec vous
également le cortège
nadège vous vous êtes vous au coeur donc
du cortège et vous suivez cette tension
également quels sont vos observations et
quels sont vos informations également
écouter à samantha cette manifestation
elle avait plutôt bien commencé ils
étaient plusieurs dizaines de milliers à
être partie au départ du ministère de la
santé pour demander plus de moyens pour
l'hôpital public
elle a dégénéré en tête de cortège vous
le voyez peut-être derrière moi sur ces
images de julien de la cour 1 on a des
forces de l'ordre qui est bien procédé à
des tirs de gaz lacrymogène on a des
voitures des barrières qui ont été
incendiés on constate de fortes tensions
à ce niveau là l'apparition des pompiers
qui viennent à d'intervenir
voilà donc on a des médecins des aides
soignants des infirmières au coeur de
cette manifestation on a aussi des
policiers qui sont venus soutenir en
civil un set cette mobilisation du
personnel soignant et c'est compliqué
parce qu'on a aussi est bien repéré
quelques quelques mètres de là la
présence de personnes masquées habillés
de noir donc voilà quelques tensions
lors de cette manifestation en tête de
cortège ça se passe un peu mieux
de l'autre côté où lé syndicat son son
les revendications elles sont elles
mêmes cette colère des aides soignants
du personnel hospitalier elles datent
pas d'hier elle date de plusieurs mois
maintenant 14 15 mois de grèves de
manifestations
et puis cette colère et bien elle a pris
un ton à la lala elle a empiré avec
l'apparition du coronavirus cette crise
sanitaire puisque ces aides soignants et
bien il était en première ligne
[Musique]
sont sentis abandonnés par le
gouvernement donc voilà ce qu'ils
réclament un parmi les principales
revendications c'est une augmentation de
salaire pour eux pour tous 300 euros de
plus par mois pour s'aligner sur la
moyenne européenne ils demandent
également à des créations à des
créations de postes et l'arrêt des
fermetures d'établissements de services
de lydie 7500 lits ont disparu au cours
des six dernières années donc voila vous
le voyez peut-être derrière nous on a un
nuage de gaz lacrymogène qui a flat ici
donc voilà les l'éloge peu ce que je
peux vous dire c'est que la tension il
est toujours aussi un palpable les
syndicats se sont réunis pour discuter
voir si la manifestation cette
mobilisation se poursuit comme elle
était prévue pour rejoindre l'assemblée
nationale ou si il est temps peut-être
de raccrocher en tout cas voilà ce que
je peux vous dire c'est que la tension
est palpable
ici dans dans cette manifestation du du
personnel hospitalier